we start today with stunning hypocrisy
uh Republican Congressman James Comer
was asked by CNN's Jake Tapper okay
you're investigating or you want to
investigate Joe Biden's handling of
classified documents after 15 or 20
documents were found in Biden's
possession which his lawyers immediately
contacted the National Archives and
turned over fine you want to investigate
that but then you must also want to
investigate Donald Trump right I mean
Trump had at least hundreds of documents
and Trump deliberately took them and
Trump used lawyers to try to avoid
giving them back rather than immediately
turning them over clearly if you're
investigating Biden you must also want
to investigate Trump and James Comer
can't explain why he's investigating Joe
Biden and not Donald Trump this is
brazen hypocrisy obvious partisanship a
humiliating double standard but
it's Republican politics in 2023 and it
has been for a while let's take a look
and Jake Tapper visibly exasperated
because what James Comer is saying makes
no sense whatsoever let's go there
because you're talking about the Trump
documents former president Trump is
under an investigation for his own
classified documents they're about 20 in
the case of Biden from Trump they're
about there are more than 300 classified
doctors in Mar-A-Lago a big difference
here uh just on the facts Trump did not
fully comply with the subpoena his
lawyers falsely told investigators that
they turned everything in true um take a
listen to what you told CNN about this
situation last November this gets good
I don't know much about that that's not
something that we've requested
information just to see what was going
on because I don't know what documents
were at Laura Largo uh so you know by
the way Mara Largo listen we went to
mar-a Largo and there were no documents
right well because that's not the place
something we're just waiting to see what
comes out on that but is it fair
that will not be a problem so what do
you say to viewers who don't understand
why President Biden's documents seem
like a big priority for you yeah but
president Trump who took hundreds more
documents did not comply with the
subpoena did not reach out to the
National Archives or the justice
department to say hey we found these
documents it's not a priority do you
only care about classified documents
being mishandled when Democrats do the
mishandling yes that's absolutely right
right Jake I'm a partisan hack
absolutely not but we still don't know
what type of documents president Trump
had that's one of the questions we've
asked National Archives just because Joe
Biden's lawyers said they turned over
five documents doesn't mean they just
turned over five documents they could
have turned over 500 documents uh I'm
sorry but I don't have a lot of
confidence in President Biden's personal
lawyers at the end of the day the
National Archives implied to us at
former chairman Maloney's request and
told us that the National Archives was
working with the Trump Administration
during the transition that's the last
communication we had with whether or not
the archives had worked if you are
confused and you're wondering where is
the answer about why we care more about
the Biden thing than the Trump thing
with the documents if you're searching
in this clip for that answer it's not
there that's why you're confused Trump
on uh removal of of all the documents
from the White House we don't know
exactly what uh Trump has versus what
Biden has and part of the reason they
don't know if they is they've said the
Trump aspect of this just isn't a
priority they're not trying to find out
end of the day my biggest concern isn't
to classify documents to be honest with
you my concern is how there's such a
discrepancy in how former president
Trump was treated by raiding Mar-A-Lago
by getting the security cameras by
taking pictures of documents on the on
the phone this is a circular I hope that
many of you recognize this is completely
circular he says listen I don't care so
much about the difference in the
documents I care about the difference in
how they were treated but of course to
understand the difference in how they've
been treated so far you have to
understand the difference between the
documents you have to understand the
difference between the number of
documents you have to understand that
Trump said take these documents to my
house whereas with Joe Biden everything
we know is that we're talking about
somewhere between one and two dozen
documents that Joe Biden didn't say keep
these put these in a box and put them
next to my Corvette this clearly was an
oversight which was immediately
turned over to the National articles if
you don't understand that then you
wouldn't understand the difference in
the treatment but that's exactly what
James Comer wants by going through
melania's closet yeah okay so that's uh
a complete inability or unwillingness to
explain what the difference is and James
Comer doesn't have any answers because
the answer is actually the simplest one
he's a partisan hack and he only cares
about the Biden documents because
Biden's a Democrat and comer is a
republican now Jake Tapper tried again
on this and said okay why are you asking
for the visitor logs for the Biden White
House for Joe Biden rather but not for
Mar-A-Lago or Mara Largo as Comer said
um and it's uh the answer will will just
whatever the opposite is of a light bulb
going off that's what it is I I get that
but there's a big difference in how
President Biden and his team sorry this
is the wrong clip okay here nope that's
the okay I don't have the clip all right
well that's too bad that went that went
bad anyway uh I don't know where the
clip went and I apologize that the clip
has disappeared the question from Tapper
was why are you asking for the visitor
logs for Biden and not from Mar-A-Lago
and James Comer said well we're in the
middle of a Biden family influence
peddling investigation which is of
course an investigation that we knew
they would do but is a complete
distraction from actual things taking
place in the real world so even
Republicans aren't able to explain
why the Biden documents are a big deal
but the Trump documents are not we are
left to speculate my speculation takes
me to well it's because Trump's a
Republican and these hacks are also
Republicans